[Music]
[Applause]
uh let's bring in marcus spears the espn
nfl analyst contributor to getup nfl
live sportscenter
and uh was a big hit last time he was on
the show uh marcus thanks for joining us
i'm curious that it feels like we can
blame patrick mahomes i don't know if
we're giving the bengals enough credit
for what they did in the second half to
him defensively so where do you start
yeah i'm starting with the bengals man
like i'm starting with the team that won
because they they earned it
and and it was to me
one of the better adjustments second
half defensively that i've seen in a
long time
and what they did was because when you
playing against that type of talent you
have to sacrifice something
or you got to find like a middle ground
to say hey our percentages
will give us more of an opportunity to
get off the field on third down or more
opportunities to put the ball back in
joe burrows hands and when they went to
that three-man rush and using a
d-lineman to spy
like they did with hubbard when they
start rushing and you know i get hyped
dp because this d-line talk i'm talking
about now i get when i start talking
about this but those guys were like and
i i make this analogy all the time on
nfl live
those guys up front were like a
basketball team
where when you pressing
we are running we are trying to run you
into a trap
we are trying to run you into
a force trap to either make you call
timeout to make you turn the foot turn
the ball over or make a bad pass
and that's exactly what they did earlier
in that game first half
as a d-line coach i'm looking at
everything unfold and i'm thinking to
myself
i just watched patrick mahomes a week
ago rushed for 70 yards against the
buffalo bills because they were
undisciplined in their pass rush
but i also saw the buffalo bills rushing
forward
and not having enough guys in coverage
with pat having enough time to take
advantage of that so what the bengals
did was they said look we're gonna turn
our defensive line
into a basketball team and we are going
to press
but we also are not going to give up the
d-ball over the top and
the guts that you have to have to say
that i'm gonna give patrick mahomes two
to three more seconds
to survey but this is our best pa best
path forward and to see those d-linemen
executed at that level this game was
about hendrickson hubbard reader this
game was about those guys up front
saying we are going to sacrifice numbers
we are going to sacrifice trying to get
sacks or makes fast splash plays and we
going to contain petrol homes and these
eight guys in coverage got to handle
their responsibility on the back end to
make him hold it long enough for us to
eventually get some pressure on second
half three of eight 15 yards an
intersect uh interception sacked four
times this is a three-man rush
yes
dp i'm telling you dude i would i would
what you expect what i expected
from eric the enemy and andy reid is
what i got from the cincinnati bengals
coaching staff
their adjustments casey abandoned the
run i know and against what they were
doing in cincinnati you got to run the
football you have and we've been
screaming this dp you have to run them
out of that defense
you got to run it out of them you got to
screen it you got to get quick passes to
the outside edges and allow your
playmakers to make plays they
consistently drop back and try to go
downfield let's let pat survey dude it's
eight people back there
let's hand the football off let's make
them adjust and the reason why the
kansas city chiefs even ended up in that
position is because they decided at a
large part of this season that we're
gonna get mckinnon involved we're gonna
get clyde there was hillary involved
we're gonna get williams involved we're
gonna throw quick quick dump passes the
mikko harmon we gonna get the ball in
tariq hands quickly and in this game for
some reason watching the cincinnati
bengals play you
in order for you to throw underneath
they did not do it and they did not run
the football and it played right into
what cincinnati wanted to do defensively
and also and i don't know if it's fair
to say it but i thought it in real time
that ego was playing into the kansas
city chiefs play calling at the end of
the first half kick the damn field goal
you know you get the ball to start the
second half you don't you know you don't
have to you don't have no timeouts kick
the field goal but
it just felt like
what i think is
and to your point yes kick the field
goal i screamed that to brandon staley
all season long with the chargers they'd
have been in the playoffs if he just
kicked the damn field goals or punt the
ball
but i think what happens man in those
moments
you've seen patrick mahomes make those
plays so much
that you become drunk to it
and
that is another part of me saying
because
here here's what i have to imagine andy
reid was thinking all right
i'm i'm gonna trust my quarterback
because we see lamar do it with john
harbaugh all the time i'm gonna trust my
quarterback
and eat with five seconds on the clock
if nothing's there he's gonna do what he
did the previous play
and throw the ball in the ground we're
gonna have a second or two left and we
can kick the field goal
patrick mahomes
was the issue on that plate and i get
what you're saying dp 100 understand it
but for my homes to not know that
situation
and not understand and and the the
perplexing thing is he did it the play
before
he killed the play he threw it into the
ground and then he threw a swing pass
now i got because there's so many sides
to this all right what patrick mahomes
is thinking also is i got the fastest
man
on on any football team in the nfl in
the flats
he's gonna make a guy miss and get in
the end zone like let's give eli apple a
tremendous amount of credit for coming
up and making that play
and football is always like that
hindsight right like don't throw it to
the don't throw it to the to the outside
to tyree kill but how many times will we
say that tyreke hill matched up
man-to-man we can get the ball in his
hands quickly and let's see if he can
make a guy miss because most of the time
majority of the time that's what happens
and i think that's what andy reid was
thinking and i think that's what pat was
thinking on that particular throw but he
should have deaded that ball dp and just
kicked the field goal he's marcus spears
former nfl lineman he'll be on nfl live
today the entire week at four eastern
and uh you can see that crew they'll be
at uh the super bowl super bowl coverage
on the mother ship as well all right
let's turn our attention to the rams and
niners
it was 10-7
and if if
i i couldn't believe the niners were
leading
it just felt like the rams made it look
easy first drive and i'm just
i'm i was trying to figure that game out
it felt like it was a a heavyweight
boxing match where styles make a map you
know a a boxing match but i didn't know
if either could deliver the knockout
blow
what was the big difference between
you know the rams winning or the niners
losing
look no further dp and it's going to be
boring because we love talking about
stafford and the offense
the san francisco 49ers had 50 total
yards rushing
they don't win like that
bebo samuel had seven rushes for 40
something yards
elijah mitchell had 11 rushes for 40
something yards or not even 40 like 38
or something like that i just looked at
it
and that is not conducive dp what i've
been saying bro and and this is this is
where jimmy garoppolo comes into the
fall right because we always we go back
and forth i think jimmy garoppolo is a
solid to good nfl quarterback i do i
firmly believe that
but if i'm a defensive guy if i'm raheem
morris i want jimmy garoppolo to win the
game
that's how i want to live with the san
francisco 49ers
and let's go through a couple sequences
of events right
you
you miss kittle over the middle
which
potentially could have been
if not a touchdown you get three points
out of that right that was a huge
you miss i think brandon iu backside and
jaylen ramsey drops the interception
you
there's all there i'm going i got both
games in my head dp this is my sheet
this is my sheet from the game
breakdowns i'm breaking i'm breaking the
games down but but i think there was
another another potential for
interception as well
but what the rams did
from a defensive standpoint was
they got this game in jimmy garoppolo's
hands
and what the rams were thinking is i got
aaron donald i got von miller i got
leonard floyd greg gaines who's been
playing phenomenal by the way doesn't
get a lot of credit big defensive tackle
um and asian robinson has been playing
well those two guys particularly a sean
robinson and greg gaines helped with the
run they did a phenomenal job defending
the run
but dp this is why you have closers
this is why you go get von miller this
is why you go get everything from if
you're the kansas city chiefs this is
why you signed a trey hendrickson in the
offseason if you the cincinnati bengals
because playoff games comes down to this
do you have the quarterback that's gonna
make the play or do you have the closers
think about when peyton won his super
bowl in denver it was demarcus ware and
von miller those were those were the
closers so the rams got this game in
jimmy garoppolo's hands late in the game
and they got the best closers in the nfl
or one of the best if not the best ever
in aaron donald and i'm not just talking
about that particular play i'm talking
about a sequence of events that leads up
to this game being in jimmy garoppolo's
hands see sean mcvay felt comfortable
with his quarterback
and the game being in his hands late in
the game kyle shanahan coaches around
that
he tries to coach around that but when
demo samuel doesn't have those big 20
and 30 yard impact plays he had the one
screen that he took to the crib
and other than that that was it and then
shanahan didn't get the ball
in debo's hands
late in the game either there's a lot of
blame to go around dp but if you want to
break this game down in a nutshell like
you just asked me i said a lot to say
this they gave up 50 yards of russian
and they made jimmy garoppolo beat him
and he couldn't do it now jimmy in week
17 in the in the regular season he made
all of the throws in the second half to
get that team the lead to get san
francisco the lead and even still
with that evidence that raheem
had he still said
let's get this game in jimmy garoppolo's
hands and we feel good about our chances
uh
why are the rams only three and a half
point favorites over the bengals at home
in the super bowl because joe burrow is
that dude bro
like we
the the there's no more obviously
denying it but
i think when you look at like cincinnati
even through this run we are still
trying to wrap our head around
your offensive line not being elite and
you about to play in the super bowl
but it speaks to the talent dp and
that's what it is
man it's jamar chase when jamal chase is
being doubled it's t higgins going off
for a hundred yards it's tyler boyd
making plays when you need runs
it's joe mixon and i'm gonna get our
offensive line some credit in that they
they they created paths in order to make
i don't think because cincinnati won and
we get blinded that last drive to get a
suit a field goal was elite
that is what we expect from the teams
that we've grown accustomed to making
those type of drives
in that game
after patreon's turnover in overtime
the cincinnati bengals went to a
physical run game
and they said joe burrow you got to lead
the way with a few throws
all right and we looked at this team two
weeks ago gets
their quarterback got sacked nine
times dp
and they won the freaking game man
so ultimately
what is happening now
the cincinnati bengals or people are
starting to realize
that that dude that wears number nine he
can overcome a lot of deficiencies that
they have as a football team
and then we have to pick our pausing
offensively because if we do double
jamar chase
we got they got some other guys that can
make you pay in some one-on-one
situations and when you found
the one-on-one with chase late in the
game it was a touchdown
so
i i understand it now i think this is
the toughest match up for based on what
i just said about aaron donald von
miller and all of those guys i think
this is the toughest matchup i think if
i think if aaron donald has joe burrow
in his grasp like chris jones did
and he misses that first tackle aaron
donald can run joe burrow down
and make the second play as far as
trying to clip his legs from under those
are the game changing tight plays dp
because
like we we never imagined a blowout in
the super bowl we never imagined that a
team is gonna come out
um like seattle did denver and and that
the game just goes like that and you
like dang man that was that was very
anti-climactic you know when we started
thinking about it but
since he just got something and and to
your point what you asked me earlier
that defense
amen
like if eli apple is not getting
exploited
in in certain situations in coverage and
the woozier is not getting taken
advantage of and they can protect those
guys a little bit because i think bates
and bale on the back end as good a
safety combo as you can get in the
league outside of poyo hyde in buffalo
that defense up front though with
hendrickson the way reader has been
playing the run
hubbard and what they're able to adjust
and morph into they are big to dp their
physical defensive line think about this
too
the cincinnati bengals don't have those
240 pound defensive ends
they don't they got those big physical
guys that can stay on the field one
through three downs and they are elite
enough to rush the passer so this this
this is a good football team outside of
what we've seen from that offensive line
at times
and look man
like
you know i'm a louisiana guy i'm an lsu
guy
you can believe it if you want to
benign just has it
just has that special gene that that in
those moments
i bet you dp in those damn moments with
joe burrow
we could check his blood pressure and it
or his heart rate it'll be at a resting
pace
who he is man yeah
could you bench
orlovski mina kimes and laura rutledge
all three at the same time
yeah no doubt yeah i think all three of
them together may be 340.
[Laughter]
but i can't throw keyshawn in there
you throw keisha now i can't get him
i can't put damian woody in there either
can't do that either maybe by yourself
but not not not with others
that would otherwise be yeah thank you
bud have a great week and uh thanks
again for joining us as always man i
look forward to talking to you again
that's marcus spears espn nfl analyst
and he'll be
on nfl live monday through friday at 4
eastern